مجلس حقوق الانسان سيتعين عليه ان يقرر ما
اذا كان سيعين فريقا من المحققين رفيعي
المستوى لتسليط الضوء على جميع انتهاكات
حقوق الانسان المرتبطه بقمع الاحتجاجات في
ايران وفقا لمشروع القرار الذي قدمته
المانيا وايسلندا ينبغي ان تركز هذه
البعثه الدوليه المستقله لتقص الحقائق على
العنف القائم على اساس الجنس ويتضمن ذلك
جمع الادله على الانتهاكات وتخزينها
لاستخدامها في الملاحقات القضائيه
المحتمله في المستقبل على ماذا شهرين قتل
مالا يقل عن اربع مئه وسته عشر شخصا بينهم
واحد وخمسون طفل وفقا لمنظمه ايرانيه غير
حكوميه لحقوق الانسان مقرها النرويج وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه كانت قد شدت في وقت
سابق على موقع تويتر على اهميه محاسبه
المسؤولين عن الضحايا من جانبها تعمل
ايران على التصدي لقرار مجلس حقوق الانسان
في حاله سماتها واكدت انها شكلت لجنه
لدراسه الاحداث الاخيره وستبحث تقاريرها
للاطراف الداخليه والخارجيه قائله ان
الغرب لا يمكن له الادعاء بالدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان نظرا لتاريخه الطويل من الاستعمار
وانتهاك حقوق الانسان للدول الاخرى متهمه
اطرافا خارجيا باثارت هذه الاحتجاجات
احتجاجات عقبه وفاه الشابه مهسا اميني
بعتها من قبل شرطه الاخلاق لارتداءها
ملابس غير لائقه كما قالت الشرطه وتحولت
الى تحدي كبير للسلطه لم يسبق له مثيل في
نطاقه والطبيعته منذ الثوره الاسلاميه عام